this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the joint is brought to you by
express vpn
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like walking your dog without a
leash guys
you'll probably be fine but what do you
know when the dog runs away what are you
gonna do
protect your internet browsing with the
best express vpn did you know every time
you connect to an encrypted network like
in a coffee shop or airport your online
data is not secure did you know any
hacker on the same network can gain
access and steal your personal data no
you didn't did you know that expressvpn
creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so they can't
get in there i take a hacker with a
super computer he'll take a hacker with
a super computer over a billion years to
get past
expressvpn's encryption expressvpn works
on all your devices phone laptop tablet
even your smart tv and it's easy to use
just fire up the app
click on to one of the buttons you get
protected and you know like your uncle
joey likes to look at creepy things from
time to time if you do too and want to
be protected listen to your uncle joey
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for free at expressvpn.com
joey i'm gonna give you three months for
free that's expressvpn.com
joey one more time
expressvpn.com
joey live life to the fullest guys
if you don't have expressvpn you can't
see no creepy things on the internet the
joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion when it comes to cbd everybody
thinks they're [__] a genius but
nobody knows dick you know who knows
about cbd
c b d
lion go to their website go to their
webpage read on the third party lab
results the percentages what to take
they break it down for you they make it
easy but it starts with you by going by
going to cbdlion.com
take a look read
find which one works for you whether
it's the gummies
the cream
the tincture which is fantastic guys the
capsules the [__]
tape listen
cbd line is the best pressing code joey
joint and get 20 off delivered right to
your [__] crib
c
b
d lion and the joint is also brought to
you by zip recruiter do you know 90
percent of employers
planned to make employee experience a
top priority in 2022 did you know that
after all a happy workplace is key to
keeping great employees
employees offering flexible work
schedules and working from home are
gonna make it big this year and if you
need to add more employees to your team
there's zip recruiter and right now you
can try zip recruiter for free
gratis just head over to
ziprecruiter.com
slash joey their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles
fast whether you're a big company small
company four out of five employers who
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day can you
beat that no no wonder zip recruiter is
rated number one hiring site in the us
of va and you're sitting there
scratching your head
find the right employees for your
workplace with zip recruiter try it for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
joey again that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 9th of march
thank you for joining us for another
fun-filled episode of the [__]
joint
i want to welcome our spotify people
say hello to you [__] i'm ready
for you with my little laughing gas
shirt found exclusively at the ice cream
shop the best weed out there but anyway
it's a beautiful day i want to talk to
you guys about something to help you
understand what's going on
uh unless you live in a [__] cave
you know that cane velasquez got
arrested last week for attempted murder
and
[__] nine other charges you know
his
in our world
in our [__] world
right here
that [__] shooting was justified as
[__]
but the problem with that is it's not
our world
it's not the way we want to run it but
in our world
that shooting is justification even the
cops turn around
you shot a [__] convicted child
molester that's out on [__] bale that
you know
had uh touched your kid over 100 times
i mean that's some [__] anger i don't
know if it's his child i don't know if
it's his niece i don't know if it's his
nephew
but it's something listen man i'm a
criminal
i did time
i have done a lot of [__] bad things
in my life
and uh
listen if you get in trouble it's none
of my business when i went to prison i
never asked somebody
what they were in there for if they did
something that heinous
the word gets out and you just stay the
[__] away from them like rape
or whatever and you pray to god that
they never crossed you because
all those people that are in prison for
rape and child molestation like child
molesters they keep them on a different
side of the [__]
jail you know because they know they're
gonna get them [__] knocked out of them
when they get in there so they keep them
in pc protective custody or on the other
side of the jail you know when kane got
arrested
it was great the next day
listen if you if you saw everybody
had a hashtag a free cra free cane
now that's nice that's [__] great you
know
that's really gonna set him loose i mean
it's a
it's a nice gesture you know
but we live in a [__] real world here
no judge is gonna look at free kane and
go oh people on twitter want me to let
uh kane out because you know people on
twitter are [__]
posting free cane it don't [__] work
that way
and then what made it worse was him
going into court on monday
and they re revoked his bail zero bail
because they said he's a threat to the
community he's not ready well
here's the deal guys you never know how
much in trouble you are until you get in
trouble let me refrain that you don't
know
how much trouble you're in
to your [__] get in trouble
okay one day i
talked to some guy that i kind of like
by the way the guy kidnapped called me
back the other day i was sleeping but he
called them with me he left me a message
so i'm going to call him back today and
uh tell him i've been thinking of them
and [__] okay
you know one day some kid came up to me
talking about cocaine and stuff i knew
the guy
the guy wasn't a heavy you know and in
my [__]
addicted cocaine fiend mind
i decided to [__] kidnap to do with
somebody not kidnap him rob him with
somebody else i didn't even know what
the word kidnapping [__] meant i
thought i had to put you in a closet and
call your uncle and ask for five hundred
thousand and your uncle tells me doesn't
have the money that's what i thought
kitten happened was i don't know rich
people who you're gonna kidnap that's
rich
my intention on november 18th
1987 was to
wake up that day
and rob cantonville
in my mind guys at the time
what i was doing this this was an
everyday thing for me
this was an everyday thing for me
so when i went up to mike and i'm like
mike i'm thinking of robbing this
[__] dude
you know if mike was my buddy and he
hears me every day talking about at
least i got a new spot for us to bro you
know it's just your world
that's your world when you're a criminal
every week you get a different mind [__]
you get like four different mind [__]
you gotta assume
three of them are going to go down you
know you go to break into a place to
have a dog you know you go to another
place they got an alarm
the bookies got his grandmother lives
with him all the time so you can't you
know so there's always uh
[__] that's not gonna go through that's
why you gotta have it's like life you
gotta have 19 things going on hopefully
one will [__] pan out so
like i said you don't know how much
trouble you until you get in trouble i
picked the kid up that day brought him
to
tidwell's house we put a gun to him
listen
when they [__] told me that i had a
warrant out for kidnapping and stuff
i was blown away i had no idea
what kidnapping even was
when they were like kidnapping one two
aggravated robbery second-degree
burglary accessory to a felony
[__] crime of violence
if you [__] get convicted of the
crime if you take it to court and it
gets convicted it's double the [__]
sentence the thing they have in colorado
for violent offenders did you think i
knew all this then
when i got down there they were blowing
my [__] mind first off let me tell
you how much of a criminal i was i was
in shock
that they were looking to arrest me
honest to god
i was in shock i remember going in there
and tell them like listen i was getting
the drug flow off the streets i'm doing
a better job than the [__] dea is you
understand me
what the [__] are you talking about i'm
in your [__] side i tried to rob a
guy and they're like what are you
talking about
what are you talking about that's how
[__] coked up and demented i was
that's the the mind of a [__] addict
kane is not an addict kane is a
sweetheart of a guy i'm not dear friends
with him i've met him a few times at
comedy shows up in san jose with daniel
cormier and those guys very nice guy i
don't [__] say much
you know when i
uh
read that he had been arrested and stuff
and i read that what he had been
arrested for
drugs never came into my mind whatsoever
cain is not a boozer
or a [__] druggie or for my knowledge
you know he spotted the guy and he
chased him uh
and shot and you know shot at the car
tried to jam the car
uh
then he shot at the car then he injured
the [__] petty's [__] father
and uh
you know they arrested him for all this
[__] reckless behavior which is not good
you know there was a couple charges
there that don't [__] look good in
his
back now
i have a lot of
uh
similarities to cane you know i have a
child
i have children i uh
have a lot of nieces i have a lot of
nephews i have a lot of friends who have
kids i like their kids
so molestation isn't high in my [__]
world either i don't understand that i
don't understand a lot of [__] things
i'm watching odds
and these guys are sucking each other's
dicks and giving each other's massages
and [__]
i don't understand that world if you're
into it to reach his own but i don't
ever want a man's dick in my mouth i
don't want my dick in my mind i don't
want any dicks in my mouth
to get to the bottom of this [__] right
you know i don't understand a lot of
[__] today california has
a nobel law whatever the whole country's
got it zero bail what if it caught any
[__] crime where you could get let
off in the street right now
they're doing it
by the [__] and we just got [__]
strict orders the whole state of new
jersey
not to leave your garage door open in
the [__] car and not to leave your
keypad in the car because they're
stealing cars all over here all over
this [__] area and they take them to
newark the problem in new jersey is
you can't follow a stolen car like a car
chase in la you can't do it here in new
jersey so they have to radio ahead to
get the borders
police so if you border in new jersey
and head into pennsylvania don't call
pennsylvania to chase you and arrest you
or baltimore anyway it doesn't [__]
really matter i'm just talking to you
guys about laws and whatnot
i'm sure kane spotted him
he's spanish
that blood
lit on you know something lights that
blood on fire
and he chased this guy you know thinking
he was going to do the right thing you
know it's like dana white said
a lot of people talk about if somebody
touches my kid i'm going to shoot him 50
times a lot of people talk about it
kane
he did it he went and did it so
in my world on this podcast kane has my
respect
but for people who follow kane and the
big fans of kane and i get you camera's
a great [__] heavyweight but all that
stuff doesn't matter in the court of law
you know i read the other day that dana
and a bunch of fighters and
people wrote letters for him that's
[__] fantastic
because in the big picture
you know if the
judge has political aspirations
we want to
get some of those charges [__] down
or whatever when you have a judge or a d
or district attorney
with political aspirations
they look at every letter as 250 people
you got to remember when you die
you get 250 mass cards that's what the
funeral director gives you because they
assume
that everybody knows 250 people
so a da's nightmare a judge's nightmare
especially one with political
aspirations
he doesn't want
you know those letters if you get 100
letters that's you know whatever times
250 [__] people and i'm not saying
you're going to tell everybody but if
you have 12 people in your closed circle
you're going to talk about how this
judge uh sentenced your son or daughter
in a in a weird way i'm going to tell
you something i'm a victim i'm not a
victim
i'm uh
you know i spent time in the
correctional facility i know
people who have
done time i know you know i grew up in
that world i'm not proud of it but
that's the way life is
it's tough to convince a [__] judge
it's very tough you know this is going
to be a hard road
for kane i appreciate what he did i love
what he [__] did
this is clint eastwood at his best this
is charles bronson at his best you know
but in this world we have laws
one law that you always have to
understand
that the district attorney spoke about i
love all this law [__] that's why i
could talk about this [__] for years i
love looking at it we're going to touch
base on this trial everything as it goes
along because this is going to be
[__] interesting
as [__]
when it plays out
listen i think at the end of it all kane
will do 10 years
you know uh he's got to get a great
attorney
to turn that situation
into a non-violent situation
that's gonna be [__] rough that's
rough to do
to convince the jury that this guy
who
shot at a car and chased somebody
during daylight hours i'm supposing it
happened don't quote me on it
in a busy street
see it's like with me when i turned
myself in
you know i was talking to the cops i was
i was trying to be
i was trying to do as much as i could by
tiptoeing around the situation if you
know anything about me i'm very good at
that i don't i won't have to bring it up
i'll have you talking about the cuban
missile crisis i have you talking about
the food network you know i just
throw you the [__] into a different
but the main thing with me was that
there was whatever there's a weapon
any weapon a knife
a stick
a gun
even if you don't use that weapon in
your confrontation
when i confront mike if i just yell at
him
and then it goes out when i punch mike
but i have that weapon on me
or it's on the floor or whatever
they're to note that the judges and the
district attorneys are going to note
that
and now
you have what's called a potential
for greater violence
a potential for greater [__] violence
and when they tell you that that means
you're up a [__]
creek without a [__] paddle okay
kane was shooting first of all he was
chasing somebody
which is never [__] good they'll
throw you under the [__] jail trust
me i've chased some people in the car
myself
i didn't know they were gonna throw me
under the jail and then
in boulder a friend of mine chased
somebody they gave him like four [__]
years you'd be surprised
of this [__] a buddy of mine got into an
argument with a mailman [__]
smackdown this [__] had a
national warrant looking for him
because it's federal you can't touch a
[__] mailman you'd be surprised
the [__] you don't know about you know
and in life listen
i mean right now i'm 59 years old
if that was to be my daughter
and i'm not telling you not to seek
[__] revenge we live in the united
states of america you know
i'm not here to glorify [__]
vigilantes but i kind of like the
[__] idea i'm a charles bronson dude
i watched death wish i grew up on all
those
type of movies and
sometimes when it comes to those type of
crimes you're not going to get
the result that you want to get in a
rape
in a [__] molestation [__] you have
no idea how hard it really is to get a
conviction on those so what if i came to
you right now
what happens tomorrow you [__] go to
work you kiss your girlfriend goodbye
go to work she comes [__] home
and she tells you that uh
she's been raped
okay
you fly to the [__] hospital you know
you talk to the cops you help a home
blah blah blah this is your [__]
girlfriend
and all of a sudden uh a week before the
[__] case or two weeks after the
arrest or whatever the [__] going on
you got a call that the court got you
know the case got dismissed
because of some [__] uh thing now how
do you feel
the girl that you love that you're gonna
[__] marry
just got raped by a guy he got his name
you got where the [__] he lives you got
all this [__] now
that guy who raped somebody where do you
think he's gonna [__] he's got 200
000 the bank to pick up and [__]
leave he's going to be at that house for
a [__] while okay
you have
you have an option of how to do this
and it's it's based on a lot of [__]
control
because okay you could shoot right over
there right now
and [__] shoot them or beat them up
or whatever but you're gonna be the
[__] prime suspect
everybody knows revenge is a dish serve
[__] cult
you know kane went after that guy like a
day or two don't quote me on this i mean
i could find out for you a day or two
after the guy had been let out
on bail for the assault on his nephew
niece
son daughter i don't know don't quote me
so
you know he didn't let it play out
that's what the mistake that kane did
he didn't let it [__] play out give
it a couple days
let the guy get i mean kane was waiting
for him where they go got got their
monitor
so supposedly but they were gonna go get
a monitoring device for the [__] guy
he had like home arrest
and kane was there waiting for him or
whatever [__] beautiful move
but he also had four [__] witnesses
three witness got his mother there he's
got his father there so obviously
kane
lost his cool
and this is
why he was not let out on bail
so
you know everybody's sitting there
everybody's talking the reason why i
wanted to talk about this today is
so you're a little bit educated listen
i'm no [__]
attorney i'm no [__] defense attorney
but i know the [__] judicial system i
played the [__] judicial system
you know i played the system as much as
i could you have to play the system if
you have the opportunity to there's
nothing wrong with that in kane's
situation he's going to sit there for a
few weeks
hopefully get some more letters maybe do
an evaluation
couple [__] things have a prison
psychiatrist talk to him
and then see where he's at and then
maybe do a bail but they're gonna have
monitoring
he has to remove all the weapons from
his house it's going to be a [__]
nightmare it's going to be a nightmare
kane's about
to face a nightmare and again in our
world he's a man's man
this is what you do
with one of those [__] but
there's always a better way to do things
christmas 1994
i got a [__] call
and i know i know what it is to lose
your mind
you know i can't
say nothing negative about kane number
one i won't number two
i'm the same [__] dude when it comes
to that
it took me a couple days to do this
because i wanted to get all the facts
and i wanted to be able to talk about it
correctly now
in christmas 94
i got a call like
three days before christmas that i'm not
getting my daughter for christmas
that my ex-wife said naomi you know what
i'm saying now
guys 94 was not a great [__] year for
me it wasn't a bad year for me
but what i'm trying to say is i wasn't i
wasn't doing great i was struggling as a
comic i was trying to find my way
as a comedian and then the scene i was
trying to get good at comedy
i was trying to pay child support i was
trying to get back on my feet i had a
lot of [__] [__] going on and you
know what nothing was coming together
the only thing that was working for me
at that time the only thing that was
keeping me alive
was standing up [__] comedy
it was the only thing when i would wake
up my eyes and i would go why do i want
to stay out of prison today
is stand up [__] comedy because i had
had it
my life was [__] rougher than [__] i
was struggling
you know i had no [__] money i had to
pay attorney bills i'm addicted to coke
i want to [__] snort coke you know i
got all these [__] things going on
and i gotta go to war with this woman
now
i get a call three four days before
christmas
i'm not gonna get my child
when you're already when your engine's
running on high you'll be getting your
car
and you're shifting or whatever the [__]
and you hear your car go
and you look at it and you're revving
like at four that's not good and you
step on it it rubs up to like eight or
nine that's not good you're putting a
lot of [__] pressure on that engine
well
some days you were if you had to [__]
judge yourself
you know when you got a lot of stuff
going on at home and your wife's giving
you a hard time
you got a rash you know you got a
thousand things you got a thousand
[__] things you know
yeah you got a [__] rash
it's a nightmare
everything seems a little rougher in
your life
you know right now my point in my life
when
when i stub my toe on the bed when i go
pee at four in the morning
i don't hold my foot and say [__] life
you know it's you stubbed your toe joey
you stubbed your toe what happens i know
it hurts rub it
kiss it and go to [__] sleep you know
but when you're angry and you're already
in pain
and your engines revving already
that toe hurts a lot more
you ever think of that
it's like if you go through a lot like
let's say you
let's say uh your dog gets hit by a car
your mom dies a week later and then a
week later your [__]
girlfriend tells you she's dumping you
for a [__] [__] or some [__] right
like
she wants to
date a guy with a big head
whatever right and you're sitting there
that's gonna hurt a lot more than
nothing like if your dog didn't die
and if your [__] mom didn't die when
that [__] [__] comes to tell you she
wants to leave you for a little [__]
you go okay
it's not that bad but since your [__]
your world's [__]
crooked you're gonna go what the [__] a
[__]
i got a big dick you know whatever
you're gonna argue with them and go back
and forth
so
i had so much [__] going on in my life
when he called me and said i wasn't to
see my kid
there wasn't any like i i i don't think
she wanted to drop the kid off because
there was hair in the corner
and the kid was allergic to dog oh yeah
when you get married in divorce someday
you're going to see what an ex-wife is
you're gonna lose your [__] mind
so
i immediately hit the [__] roof
i mean i remember
i didn't have a pay phone i didn't have
a [__] cell phone i had a pager the
attorney paid me and i had to walk to
the [__] gas station and call the
attorney and then he would call me to
[__] back and oh i would call him
and then uh he would tell me the bad
news all the time so now i had to walk
home
knowing i wasn't going to get my child
it was like a 100 yard walk you know not
size of a football field wasn't [__]
far
by the time i got home guys i was
[__] burning
i was burning
and i didn't do anything
i gave myself the benefit of the doubt i
said let me sit back i mean at that time
i was uh
94 i was 31 years old
i had already been locked up and i
already knew about life
instead of me calming down
my anger went the other way
it was one of those nights where you're
too angry to fall asleep
you ever have those nights you're
[__] just too angry you get up every
two hours you smoke a little dope maybe
like at six you fall asleep for an hour
but when you wake up you're [__]
hotter than when you went to bed that
was me the next day
and i'll never forget i took a shower i
thought about it you know jingles were
in the air everybody was talking about
jingle bells and [__] snowmen and
[__] and i am [__] livid
and i went over and called the attorney
and he's like nah
they're still holding on to that guns
like you know what [__] this
and i went to my friends uh madeline and
uh danny's house the feebles is my
[__] goombas i love these cubans i
went over there madeline was home danny
was working and i'll never forget i
knocked him the screen door she opened
it she was like making
breakfast or she just was
doing something in the kitchen or some
[__] and she goes what's going on i go
listen i got a piece of meat and i gotta
borrow a big knife and she's like well
take one go ahead borrow it and bring it
back so they had like one of those knife
stands and i went and took the biggest
[__] knife they had out of that
[__] stand
and i'll bring it back later she's like
bye see you tonight i get in that
[__] car and i go i'm driving down
to my
ex-wife's
where the [__] boyfriend works
because at this time my mind
you know my mind still hadn't processed
a divorce
in my world
she had left me for some other guy so i
was gonna just kill him because i didn't
know all the facts i didn't know exactly
what was going on my first
instinct was to kill this [__]
i didn't care about comedy at that point
i didn't care about going to jail i knew
i was gonna end up in jail i was gonna
kill one of these [__]
so and this is sad this is a sad way to
[__] think
but this is what happens when you're not
mentally healthy
i was not mentally healthy at least i
admit that and i was just
broken i was [__] broken i was
aggravated you know that was a time when
i used to cry myself to sleep a lot
because i could taste the [__] comedy
and i was working hard and i couldn't
get there but i knew
that i had to have patience that if i
kept doing what i could do
i'd [__] get there but you know what
on that particular dad i didn't give a
[__] about anything i got in my [__]
car and i held onto that knife and i
shot down to where the [__] he worked
down there on
in south boulder by the 36 and i [__]
pulled into the parking lot
and i remember in the [__] car i just
sat there
for about six or seven minutes stewing
figuring out how i was gonna stab this
[__]
and i never forgot i got up
got out of the car slammed the [__]
door
walked 50 yards into the building and
that lady said to me you know can i help
you and i'm like i'm here to see [__]
[__] oh
and she's like second floor and i just
went
[__] up those stairs like a [__]
savage and when i got up to the [__]
second floor i looked and i'll never
forget there was a lady and i had
already walked past her she's like
excuse me sir sir sir and i just kept
walking i'm like and i turned thank god
i did and didn't stab her or not we
wouldn't be having this conversation
today
and i went like i'm looking for [__]
[__] oh
and she goes you just missed them to
lunch
and i'll never forget that i was like
how could that [__] be i was just
sitting out there i didn't see him leave
the building because i would have rather
stabbed him outside
but my anger i didn't give a [__] where
i stabbed this [__]
i don't know if i forgot i had like
little tears in my eyes she's like uh
he's out to lunch already you know he'll
be back in a while is there a message i
could leave
and i'm like no she had already hit like
a security button or whatever because as
she was talking to me a security guy was
walking up
i had the knife in my hand he couldn't
see it it was hidden in a
jacket they just said come back later is
there a problem like no no no i just
want to ask him a question and i was
[__] heartbroken i walked out that
[__] door
i sat in that car and i threw the knife
on the floor and i just sat there and
cried
i sat there and cried
because i know
what was about to happen if he wouldn't
have gone to lunch that day
i wouldn't have been here doing his
[__] podcast i would have just been
getting out by now or something so i
cried for like 20 30 minutes because
i realized that i had missed
the fa like
my mind was set he was going down
but god gave me a chance that day but
till this day i look at it as a [__]
chance
but if he would have been there
i was no different than cain velasquez
right or wrong that that's you acted out
you go down there and you're not
thinking about anything i wasn't
thinking about my little girl at the
time i didn't give a [__] about anything
i just knew that they weren't gonna get
my [__] child
and the way it wrapped up i went home
brought the knife back went home i cried
and later on that night the attorney
paged me he said you're getting your
[__] child tomorrow
so
it was one of those moves where i
learned my lesson
it could have been a [__] horrible
day and it turned out being a good day
because i didn't get arrested and i
learned the [__] lesson
you know in kane's situation
i love him he's got my back you know if
somebody starts to go fund me or
something because he's got gallegos
has his attorney and that [__]
that's [__] a lot of money so uh
i guess somebody's gonna have to help
him
with that i don't know what type of
money he's got left off from the ufc or
whatever but this is going to be heavy
duty i'm hoping
you know as uh
listen you don't have to be a fan of mma
you don't have to be a fan of kane or
anything like that to just take a look
at this case
just take a look at this case this is a
really [__] up case
so now kane went and tried to serve
[__]
revenge on the guy and shoot him
but now he puts his family at [__]
danger
and i don't mean danger i'm sorry well
now his family's in a struggle situation
i'm sure he's got a couple children i'm
sure he has a mortgage
i'm sure he's got a ton of [__] going on
right now and uh
i'm not mad at kane i would have done
the same [__] thing
i know 20 guys that would have done the
same thing i just wish that
kane would have done a little bit more
diplomatic
you know
uh
a lot of years at home going
maybe he didn't have to do anything
maybe he should have just let
god or maybe he should just let karma or
maybe he should just let the prison
system
interfere with this with whatever
i don't know guys
i don't know
you know anything to do with children
mike's a great guy you know mike has no
violence in his heart i can't imagine
what happened if
some day care guy touched your [__]
child i mean
it pushes a man to do
something he would never do again that's
your [__] child guy
you know i used to date a girl years ago
and she was raised in a cult
you know she told me the stories about
growing up in a cult and stuff hey
listen different strokes with different
folks i can never judge her for that but
i will tell you what i judged her for
out of that whole conversation
i dated this girl for four years and i
never particularly liked her parents
i didn't like him for a lot of reasons
but the main reason why i didn't like
him was because that
when they had a chance to raise their
daughter
they put her at risk
you know they had like seven kids
the [__] cult leader was [__] all
the kids
the cult leader was [__] the wife you
know the cult leader was [__]
everybody
listen
if i'm gonna join a cult tomorrow
it has nothing to do with my daughter
that's nothing really do with my wife
if i go to my wife and i want to [__]
join a cult
my wife is pretty level-headed she'll go
okay
you know good luck to you you know what
do you want from me
but i'm not gonna fight with my wife i'm
the type of guy i'm not gonna fight with
my wife a fight with mike to come with
me into that cult i don't believe
dragging people down in the dark alley
you you're gonna hear i've done a lot of
[__] you're gonna read the book i've
done a lot of crazy [__] i'm not big on
taking people down the dark alley i
don't think when people took me down a
[__] dark alley and when i say down a
dark alley i go joy why would you go to
that dark island not a literally a dark
alley but just to put somebody in a
weird situation
with your actions if you put somebody in
a weird situation i have a horrible
temper
there's some things i let go
and there's some things i jump on and
there's some things that
are very minuscule that i get mad about
and sometimes the big thing is you just
overlook or you have some type of
uh answer for
what happened you know you always have
some type of of whatever you know
i can't even say that i wouldn't attack
the guy myself and not thought about my
wife and my daughter if i was to see him
on the street but in the real world
knowing who i am now today at 59
i always had the ability to sit in a
bush for a long time
i love it i love that that you have to
sit in the bush
sometimes you have to wait in the bush
for a year for somebody to [__] up
and sometimes you have to wait in that
bush for eight years before somebody
[__] up
and gives you a green light for you to
[__] jump them you know
uh
in kane's situation obviously he
couldn't wait
this [__] had to get taken care of
absolutely positively like [__] uh
you know
what's the delivery company
fedex yeah when the positively has to
absolutely has to be there you know he
took care of this uh
very quickly without thinking about it
now a lot of people are in jeopardy a
lot of people in a bad position again
i'm not mad at campus i would never
judge them for this but what i'm trying
to say is
that's the thought i'm sure if he could
do this again
he would have said [__] i mean i'm sure
he knows cops in san jose
or whatever you know
there's nothing wrong with asking a cop
a question
you know did this guy get out or
whatever you know there's parameters
there's a way for cain to do this for
him to get the satisfaction
because that's when you get revenge what
are you going after
you're going after satisfaction
you want to be [__] satisfied
it's a horrible way to [__] live when
you're waiting for somebody to make a
[__] mistake
you know in 19
in the early 80s i hated my stepfather i
mean
i hate the [__] today it depends
one week you catch me on but then i was
just thinking about
all the pictures and photographs and
albums and important stuff that my
stepfather threw away
that he knew i needed and i got mad at
him the other night i swear to god maybe
about a week ago i was thinking about my
stepdad what a good guy i don't feel
like that [__] threw away all my
[__] important [__] when i was a kid
i was stalking him for a while
in 1982-83
there was nothing in the world i wanted
more to kill my [__] stepfather
and for all the wrong reasons
there were some of the right reasons but
some of them were the wrong reasons
i used to go down there and get on the
bus and go down there and hide
and i figured out that i was gonna hide
under a car
wait for him to come home at three
o'clock in the morning and shoot him
when he had a couple cocktails
over him you know in him
it was a great idea on paper did i ever
do it no
i was on that idea for about two two and
a half years and even when i came back
from colorado in 84 i went down there a
couple times just to scope out where i
was going to shoot him
i had to let the feeling go i had to let
that emotion go it was
it was taking too much of my [__]
time it was taking too much of my
[__] valuable time with when you're
angry at somebody like that it take like
right now there's a guy in l.a i can't
[__] stand
there really i mean
the guy's a [__] bona fide [__]
jackal
he's clipped from a thousand [__]
people in l.a and nobody wants to go
after this guy i'm dying to go after
this [__] guy
at any cost i don't give a [__] if they
convict me because of this i don't give
a [__]
the guy is a piece of [__] if i ran his
history by you [__] you'd say
hit him with a pipe 10 times
and then let me come out and light him
on fire that's the type of guy this guy
is and he's burned a lot of entertainers
but entertainers like [__] they don't
want no confrontation you know i
couldn't even think of a [__]
uh of why i wouldn't uh and i went after
this guy when i lived in l.a and he
threatened me with a
with a lawsuit and all this [__] and i
was like listen
let me get the other people that he's
[__] jibbed up and we'll [__] take
him to court and i reached out and i
like the eight people four of them
wanted to do something the other four
didn't give a [__] and that's when i
realized it wasn't that
it shouldn't have been that important to
me joey you you know you're doing fine
why are you mad
about i don't know how much money it is
because it's not the [__] amount of
money it's the [__] principle i don't
want to let this [__]
i don't want to let this [__]
get away with it and i got to be honest
with you
once every 10 days
i just sit here and dream of
shooting them in the hand
shooting them in the knee
beating him up i don't want him dead
i just want him [__] up like a [__]
up hand
you know [__] shoot him in the knee
both his [__] ankles you know
just so he remembers
you'll see the movie sleepers
when he [__] the guy goes when he
went in the mirror i did it to him so he
could [__] remember me same thing
just so he can remember i don't want him
dead i don't want him to be missing from
his kid's life but a good beat and every
time he looks at his hand he sees that
jesus whistle in there you ever see when
kennison said that
jesus had a [__] whistle why would he
want to come back after you turned his
hand into a whistle
whatever the [__] it was sorry about
that lord please forgive me
anyway if i was kane right now this
is how i would handle this
the revenge on the [__] pedophile
that's dead for a while
that's dead sit tight
you know i i want cain to understand
what i didn't understand
before
everything got
you know
you're gonna go to jail
i'm sorry to tell you
there's not an attorney in the world
that's gonna get you off with a [__]
right now you're seeing it right from
the bail listen
when you
commit a crime
and you go to get bail that bail should
be set right away right or wrong you
guys watch law and order and
[__] chicago pd and everything that
thing should be set right away if
there's an issue with your bail like
there is with kane right now that
issue's going to keep coming back up and
up and up up again trust what i'm
telling you
that it's either they're going to give
you bail or they're not when they reject
you that bail for that time now they're
gonna have to do
they're gonna have to do reports the
probation department goes out and does
reports does investigations
ask people about your character witness
you know whatever so right now from
kane's [__] family
i'm putting together letters
i'm
pushing mark gallegos the attorney to
set up a [__] uh
psychiatric and value
evaluation kane's not crazy he just got
caught up in the minute that kane is not
crazy
he's a as a matter of fact kane's pretty
[__] smart
if you ever heard him speak have you
ever seen him
wrestle i mean he's college educated he
was an all-american wrestler kane isn't
stupid this is just
uh the thought of molestation to a
father
is that [__] disturbing
there's nothing wrong with cain and my
world cain did the right thing
but now
how do we get out of this
with the least amount of drama well i'll
tell you what
you can't go into this type of trial or
this type of case with a [__] public
defender
that's not going to happen you're going
to end up in [__] prison
what we're going to do now this is the
way we work it out
you're already going to do time
you're going to do time i know you feel
that that the people
the the jewelries i'm going to feel
whatever for you i know that there is
going to be
a little bit of [__] remorse and
sorrow from the whatever they're going
to take down some charges and stuff but
i want you to understand in a situation
like this high profile national news
you're going to do a little time
now when you say a little time
i put a number of ten years because
they're gonna probably give them 15 with
everything they're going to drop some
[__] charges put them all together
make them all run concurrently
i give i i'm
in the neighborhood of 15 [__] years
but
you get mark gallegos
uh
you know you said there was never no
violence and keynes
uh
passed
they're gonna come back that he was a
ufc fighter you know
i mean the guy was a ufc fighter so
he is violent so right away you're on
the [__] fence either
you got paid for this or this was an
everyday occurrence if they find out
like somebody like me
because that's how you right now if i'm
kane i'm not thinking about anything
unless how i'm gonna get my sentence
lowered how can i get these numbers
lowered
let's pretend they plea bargain on a
crime that's non-violent like what
happened with me my attorney was so good
i didn't even know what the [__] he was
doing he just kept telling me we're
gonna flip this around from non-violent
i got to do
you know he's he got an investigator and
we interviewed people i grew up with and
teachers and cops and we came to the
conclusion that joey was not a crazy
[__] that he's not a violent guy he's
not going to cut your nuts off he's not
gonna eat he is like hannibal elected no
he had a bad [__] day
you know
they said i tied him in a knot you know
when i hit can't cut them whatever so
that's what they were trying to do that
i was lure on the crate with kane
they're gonna go well he tried to
[__] shoot somebody i mean that
that's
so there's some time involved
how much time
is what we're working at
so he's got a family he's college
educated he was working at the time of
his arrest all those variables [__]
count believe it or not if he had a high
school diploma college diploma family
life job
community he's gonna have to have
you know that whole listen man uh
that kickboxing academy is aka is well
known up there in that community it's
part of that community kane was a part
of that community so
i'm hoping
that uh
through all this
we get the years knocked down to ten
maybe kane could serve
six or seven
listen involuntary manslaughter i had a
friend who killed a guy at a party one
time he wasn't my friend i was i talked
to him in prison he was a biker and he
killed a guy in a room one time it was
his word against the guys
he murdered the guy but he got
involuntary manslaughter okay so
we might be able to do something here
with kane on a we need to get his charge
that he settles on but what is he
settling on he chased aggravated assault
rammed his [__] car and fought a
firearm shot a firearm i mean i'm hoping
he stopped on the way a little old lady
across the street you know what i'm
saying as he was chasing him like go
ahead lady i don't need to capture this
[__] this bad
that's what i'm hoping that they find
something that the jurors are a little
sympathetic
to what happened you know to his needs
and and
that's pretty much it you know i don't
think we'll see kane fight for a while
unless he gets out on bail
and fights once or twice just to get a
little cash before the
trial
and again
i'm not mad at kane i'm not speaking
bad about kane i just wanted to talk
about this this is a subject that i know
a lot about
you know i've been locked up i was
caught up in the same type of situation
where
you let your emotions
get the best of you before and i've been
in that situation a lot of times
when i'm 59 i'm close to i'm [__]
around in the corner at 60
and i'm just learning about this
that i've had this control for maybe
10 years 12 years
but i was also one of those idiots that
pulled guns and pulled knives
and threw bottles at people at the
comedy store i got all that [__] you
know i just uh
i learned to cope with it i have a
daughter
who i love with all my heart she's nine
years old
i protect her with everything i have i
keep her mind
you know uh
clean of all that [__] she doesn't
need when the time is right i'll [__]
fill her in myself
but if something was to happen to my
daughter in that situation what do you
think i would do
i don't care whether i'm 60 or 28.
in that situation i got to be honest
yeah i'm gonna act the same [__] way
i mean every time i go to softball every
time i do something whether
at a school event or whatever
i'm always have that apprehension that
is today the day a coach
is going to say something i got to hit
this [__] with a bat because i
wouldn't have the patience either
so i get it i get everything that's
going on
again i'm not judging kane
in fact i wish kane nothing but luck
and if i uh see a gofundme or whatever
i'll throw him some [__] patreon
money for his defense
that's how we're [__] rolling
today's march the 9th and that's it i'm
feeling good i'm smelling good i'm
[__] sleeping at night i'm smoking
reefer not as much as uh
in the old days but i'm getting my
little party on
and that's it everything is tip top
[__] magoo laughing gas is out
whether it's the sashimi
the tremendous
the [__] coco
the white truffle they got it going on
over at the ice cream shop what'd i say
four or five oh sashimi white truffle
tremendous one tremendous cocoa
white truffle now i said that rainbow
trout rainbow rutz
white truffle
coco sashimi and tremendous [__] suckers
what do you think you're dealing with
joey [__] bananas the ice cream shop
ventura and [__] colfax
right there in lancashire right there
not lancashire right there in [__]
studio city one of my favorite weed
stores in the [__] world this
is the insignia there for [__] uh
laughing gas a little coco looking
[__] good and that's it and that's
that i did hear from my friends that we
went out the other day with all of them
said they had one of the best [__]
let me tell you let me read you what
whitey sent me
you're gonna [__] love this guys this
was a
i posted the picture on instagram
of louis hernandez me and david
a lot of people understood what the [__]
i was coming at
but let me read you what my boy sent me
just so you [__] know it was
great one of the best evenings i've had
in my life thanks for putting together i
spoke to chuck yesterday next time he
will be there i will reach out to you
soon again
if you ever need anything just reach out
that's my brother [__] white top
right there
so everything's beautiful [__]
it's a beautiful wednesday
and that's it i hope you guys enjoyed
the [__] podcast today you know
i've been thinking about kane for a few
days and like i said uh
my heart goes out to him and his family
if anybody sends a go uh support a
gofundme page
for kane's legal defense please send me
a link
so uh uncle joey's patreon can [__]
help kane out and that's how i feel guys
i'm sorry
if our uh views are different
but uh
you're not [__] with a kid or a loved
one that's just the way it is that's the
way
it feels in my world so uh i love you
have a great [__] day have a great
rest of the week and i'll see you
[__] monday morning i think
it's the 14th
tip
top magoo saint patty's week stay black
[__]
all right i want to thank you
[__] for listening today
talking about my brother cain velasquez
and what he went through it's just
bad situation everybody looks a little
differently i'm telling you how i look
at it i hope you enjoyed it the joint is
brought to you by zip recruiter did you
know that 90 of employers planned to
make employee experience a top priority
in 2022
after all a happy workplace
is the key to keeping great employees we
all know that employers are offering
flexible work schedules and working from
home are going to make a big this year
and if you need to add more employees to
your team
their zip recruiter and right now you
can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
joey that matching technology helps you
find the right people
for your jobs fast four to five
employees
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day no wonder
zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the us of a
find the right employees for your
workplace with zip recruiter try it for
free at this exclusive app web address
ziprecruiter.com
slash joey j-o-e-y
that's ziprecruit.com
joey
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
c b d lion is on board today
if you're not messing around with cbd
line you're just throwing your money
away cbd lion
is the best cbd on the market how do i
know because i've lived it whether it's
a tincture whether it's the cream for my
knee whether it's the gummies to help me
sleep at night
the tape
the
they got some great [__] cbd reefer
with no thc on it but the next move is
yours go to cbd lion read the third
party lab results and then
get back to me you understand me
that cbd lion
pressing code joey
joint whatever you got
and we're gonna give you 20 off your
next order
cbdlion.com
and last but not least one of my
all-time favorites
expressvpn listen using your internet
without expressvpn it's like you're
walking your dog without a leash yeah
you'll probably be fine but what are you
gonna do when it runs away protect your
internet browsing with the best
express
vpn do you know every time you connect
to an encrypted network like coffee shop
or airport your online data is not
secure you didn't know that right any
hacker could gain access and steal your
personal data but with expressvpn you
create a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so i need i need to take a
hacker with a computer over a billion
years to get past
expressvpn's encryption expressvpn works
on all small devices phone laptop tablet
even your smart tv and it's so easy to
use just fire up the app click one
button and you're protected you know
your uncle joey likes to look at creepy
things from time to time i know you
[__] like to do if you want to
be protected you gotta listen to your
uncle joey do me a favor get
three extra months of expressvpn at
expressvpn.com
joey that's expressvpn.com
joey trust me
once you download expressvpn you're
gonna be happy you did you're gonna go
joey you're a [__] genius now you can
find everything you like knives death
stars from hong kong
steroids from germany whatever
expressvpn.com
joey i want to thank expressvpn i want
to thank cbd lion i want to thank zip
[__] recruiter the best
better help liquid iv and lucy co
for a great week i want to thank you
guys for a great week i'll see you guys
monday morning
tip top [__] magoo have a great
week and stay black
[Music]
so
you